all right free spirit
what's up Mark free spirit have we
rolling we're rolling all right peace
and love to everybody praise God praise
the high power blessings we here live
all right
um so we're uh
you're here on students you're on a skid
row but you're right read from
originally Jersey so I'm from nav
so to have is North Bergen
um Bergenline so yeah that's where we
from the East Coast New Jersey
and now we here in L.A
tell me about your family growing up
what was that your family growing up my
family growing up so
when my parents it's always been
super Rocky and never
stable so it was always like a troubled
childhood from the very beginning and um
I quickly understood that so
you know when you don't get the genuine
love from your parents so you have a
certain structure then you just try to
find your way and you isolate so
that's pretty much what it is and then
through isolation you just
figure out your own thing so
and you start going outside you start
meeting people you start experimenting
with stuff and
that's pretty much what it is I had a
lot of people around me that I've seen
growing up that had the house that had
big like you know on families and eating
everything I never really had that so
you got to learn to navigate through
life without that
how would you describe your childhood in
general
so
uh
so explaining it just disclaimer before
I don't have um any hate or like
negativity when I think of my childhood
you know a lot of people grow up they
might still hate the parents or like
[ __ ] my parents or whatever I'm at a
place now it took a long time but I'm at
a place now and throughout these recent
years where I'm just even blessed to
have life so
growing up my dad was pretty much a
reckless type he just worked 24 7.
he barely was home when he did it was no
talking or anything like that I mean
growing up maybe a few years we would
maybe play basketball a few times or go
to a few amusement parks here and there
but
That Never Was consistent
so you know when he wasn't working and
the times he would be home it would just
be isolation he'd just be in his room by
himself like my parents didn't even
sleep together like in a room like like
he had separate rooms which growing up
to me at the time you don't think
nothing of it and then that's completely
ridiculous
so he had his own bedroom and then my
mom had her own
and um yeah I'd share with my brother
and yeah so he was just like isolated
doing his thing like smoking cigarettes
in his room he'd always if he wasn't
working he'd go out with his friends and
like wouldn't tell us or my mom like
what he was doing or anything like that
so it was just like a mystery and then
like super angry like he would just
always be
arguing with my moms and then arguing
with me and the brother and just taking
it out on us you know um not sure all
the terms for abuse they have specific
ones but pretty much like everything you
could think of
so that was his story and
um so I just tried to
um disassociate from him as much as
possible so it was always friction with
him
then um if we get into my mom's side so
with my mom
we will kind of the opposite so that was
my dad's point in my mom like
um
I'd always have to like sneak out and
stuff like that because they didn't want
me leaving the house or anything like
that they tried to control a lot but um
when she was cool like we'd go out we'd
ride around and she'd be like we'd
listen to the same type of music and
stuff like that so that was cool and my
dad was the complete opposite so um
yeah
um it was cool with my mom at times but
then um eventually she started
developing some like illnesses
like sickness and certain conditions I
remember she said um lupus was one of
them I never knew what it was but she
tried to explain that some with like
muscles or I'm not sure but um for
anybody watching that knows you can
understand it I suppose so that was that
and then eventually that turned into
um the the medication route like she
would
then go to hospitals or whatever but
then eventually get like prescriptions
and then one
turned into two and then two turned into
five and five turned into ten and then
it just never ended so
it was the strangest thing like seeing
somebody that's you know I guess a
normal
and then pretty much like
deteriorate like
you know yearly monthly and then weekly
day by day and then you're seeing it so
that's why I never growing up got into
any drugs or anything like that because
I just seen the worst of it and I had my
own family going through it and then the
environment around so I seen the
negative and what it does so I never was
like oh I'm about to do this and you
it's around but seeing what it did I was
like nah I can't do that so that's
pretty much the parent summary what kind
of kid were you in high school
ah so yeah I never went to school I just
never liked it I I was always the kid
like [ __ ] school and
it's just every day it seemed to me like
now I I feel like in society we have
this like
I don't know how to explain it everybody
seems intelligent like everybody knows a
lot of information and everybody's doing
podcasts and interviews and
self-education so growing up in school
was like textbook textbook textbook this
is the way this is the way this is the
Wade and
like I just was like this is never for
me I like traveling I like experience I
like going places I like living things I
like colors and stuff and the fact that
like you gotta wake up certain time go
sit in a desk listen to somebody and I
just never liked that it was like some
institution to me so I never like school
so it's the name free spirit yeah so
um
uh oh quick FYI so for you and the
audience so free spirit so growing up
like I was explaining to
um off camera like music was my number
one thing then that branched off into
like photography uh film and then like
clothing trying to make that and stuff
so all of these things I was dabbling
with and I was just like eventually I
need a a cool artist name and I can't
have like a generic one that everybody
has or some cheesy rapper name so I just
kept thinking and then one day just hit
me I was like free spirit I was like it
summarizes pretty much everything and
like
the lifestyle that and it just stuck and
uh yeah free spirit was for a few years
before I left Jersey to come out here
then I started making it my tag and
music and my logo and then once I came
out here it just stuck like it just
stuck everywhere I go it's the leaders
say the whole thing free spirit or some
of the girls would be like Spirit or
like some of the guys would just be like
yo free so there's all different types
of it so
it just stuck I'm 26 and I'm 27 in
February so birthday is February 26th
which was trippy this year because I
turned 26 on the 26.
how far did you go in school
I dropped out junior year I got left
back in seventh grade I just wasn't
doing anything and now that I think of
it everybody was trying to clown me at
that time like laughing at me making fun
of me trying to say I was like stupid
and stuff like that
it was it was wild to me and then once I
dropped out like people started dropping
out as well and I was just like all
right cool so yeah junior year I was the
the day after my birthday I woke up and
I was like because you know you don't
need the parents to sign once you're 18.
so yeah once I turned 18 the next day I
just went and I dropped down since then
I just never went back
yeah what are your hopes to do here in
L.A
so
I left where I was from I was like all
right I'm going to LA on a one-way and
because there was none of this creative
type of space back where I was from like
nobody was doing music when I started
making music
photography when I stay it wasn't like a
few people were trying to start it out
nobody was doing music videos or
interviews or anything like that
nobody was really stylistic in terms of
having their own you know way and
setting Trends and stuff so I said okay
let me go to LA because I figured
I'm gonna be around a creative area and
I'm just gonna be able to make some type
of moves that I'm not doing here and
everybody said I was crazy
they were saying don't go people were
just like you need a plan you need to
save money first and I was just like you
know I'm going so do you have any
support from your family at all
absolutely not nah my parents left my
parents left me the day I turned 18.
they just took off so since 18 in my
mind I was like my parents are gone I
knew it was coming because like like I
said it was a rocky childhood from the
beginning so I knew I had any second
this is all going to explode but as a
kid you can't plan for any of this stuff
so you just take it on the fly as it
goes
so
I believe then I went to my grandma so
after they left because I had nowhere to
go I came home and everything was gone
in the house it's like all my stuff
everything so I left with nothing my
grandma was the only family member that
I had that I know of
so I went to live with her and then I
stayed there for a few and when I left
to La I believe I was
22 23 something like that
and yeah that was my hopes here I was
like I'm gonna just make some music here
I'm gonna get the photos going I'm gonna
expand and I'm gonna get these videos
going and I'm gonna link up with some
people to get clothing and
it was so Rocky when I first started
coming here but then I got into it moves
started happening like
I don't know how it happened I was in
different Studios every day I was
meeting people making music I was
shooting all these types of photos and
people were reposting it I was meeting
people we were doing photo shoots I was
shooting People's music videos I was
doing interviews it was a great
portfolio that I was building and then I
was just seeing how the Hollywood scene
worked
and I couldn't get down with it you know
so I I just respect anybody for whatever
profession they have that they keep
going no matter what for me I couldn't
do it the pride got in the way all that
kind of what were the problems
so coming from the East Coast there's
like nothing really
like think over there it's like you like
somebody or you don't like you just keep
it moving there's not really this like
you turn around and it's hey and then
it's just like one way and not so out
here
I left all that and I was like okay I'm
gonna start fresh in La I'm gonna just
be positive I'm gonna let the past go
and I'm Gonna Be Kind to everybody I'm
gonna open my heart to this life
and then people were just like the
problems would be
they'll be like I got you no matter what
or I'm I'm here for you or if you need a
place to stay you can stay here or
and then it was the complete opposite
like a day later people don't answer
your text they don't answer your calls
you you trying to get a place to stay
there nowhere to be found
that kind of stuff and
um
I learned like your talent
I don't know how to say it's not that
your talent don't matter but it's like
really networking out here it's like who
you know and the connections you have
and I didn't want to believe that
because growing up you hear that saying
like it's not uh what you know it's who
you know I was like nah I know I'm great
and my talent and my drive and my
passion is going break through all this
and it's just like yo it's sick out here
La is such a beautiful place but it's so
ugly and fake as well which is so
disappointing because there's so much
opportunities out here but you know
there's so many people I've met
and music that are just terrible but
they have a position and they're going
because of like the circumstances around
them where they know somebody in this
office or they know somebody on social
media that does this networking and
marketing and so there's like a story to
everything and it's it's just wow I I
will say
to
to end with this note on this topic the
craziest thing
that I've seen and I'm not gonna say no
names or whatever but this is out here
and it's real there was a little bit I
seen when I was out in the east coast
but coming out here
the the fake traffic
like
if you post a YouTube video you buying
the YouTube views
I've I've told some people this and they
don't even know it existed and I'm just
you post a song on um SoundCloud
they buy the plays you post a pic on
Instagram they buy in the comments they
like buying the likes they buying the
followers on the Instagram and
seeing that out here like
face to face it was just like disgusting
to me because I'm like wow like you have
people where I'm from thinking like I'm
gonna go to La and do this but you have
all this going on so it's like you fight
in La by itself and then that on top of
that social media popularity is a
commodity in itself
look I've seen people been with people
that literally post this way
on Instagram and in real life it's the
complete opposite
and it's like a normal thing out here
and I just couldn't get down with that
I'm like how can I be doing type of how
can I be making moves with these kind of
people every day trying to further my
career but they're doing this I just
couldn't let that pass and be like well
I'm getting my opportunity so I gotta
just ignore that and let them do them it
just that kind of stuff bothers me like
I think the craziest one of the craziest
things
this dude homeless sleeping in his car
and like
one of his YouTube videos like has a
hundred thousand views
and it's like
I know what's up and it's just sad man
there's so many people you know guys and
girls that do it and I just wish that
didn't exist because like as a society
we'd be so much better without this like
fake promotional Instagram double life
kind of stuff
yeah social media is
anybody that knows me knows I'll
struggle with the internet and like I'm
really never on it if I do something or
I post or say something I'll delete it
then I'll get off I'm mostly just trying
to be like at peace without the phone
off the grid and you know coming to La I
mean who does that so it's it's
definitely it's it's a struggle trying
to make it in a certain type of career
like this but without doing the
networking and all that
yeah yeah that's a struggle yeah a lot
of people around me they'll be getting
mad at me because of that because I'm
not on the phone like that and I don't
really do the promotion and the
Instagram they'll be getting mad at me
and I'm just like I just see what's
really I see what's really going on with
this and I just choose not to use it I
try to be positive and try to shine
light on it because I know there's so
many kids like me and just people out
there that feel the same way so we got
to keep going to show them and
uh yeah no matter how negative it is and
how I just described I feel like the
positivity will overcome it like like I
just got on Instagram today and I posted
a video I was like let's do it man like
2023 let's push forward I got a lot
going on things are up in the air but
you know let's try to figure it out
yeah if you do things I think for
yourself rather than for others right
it'll all work for you if you're if you
start doing things to please others
you're gonna right and I know there's so
many people out there that feel that way
and I the ones that get mad or feel
annoyed by it that's what you just said
they you know you're trying to do it for
them or whatever so yeah anybody out
there that's the key you gotta do things
for you no matter what you're gonna lose
friends you're gonna lose best friends
you might lose your girlfriend your
boyfriend people not understanding your
vision but you gotta remember why you
started what you did and yeah you do it
for you you're gonna be good yeah you
have a good head on your shoulders for
young
young man
like growing up I thought 21 was old
I I didn't think I'd make it to 21 let
alone 18. once I hit 25 I was like it's
over like I was like there's no way I
made it this far because I I didn't even
foresee that and then once I hit 26 I
was like
oh snap like it's just an adventure now
and I've always looked like I'm like 17
18 anyway the tattoos kind of added a
few years but
yes like 26 I'm turning 27 in February
like so many people don't even make it
to that age you know especially in music
a lot of artists and stuff they don't
even make it that far
so it's it's like it's a weird time but
it's like special at the same time that
you overcame this much so I'm like I
know God still got me here for a reason
you know we on this Quest and it's
nowhere near done yet so I'm excited for
this new year for show tell me about
your face tattoos
yeah so
first let me ask why first yeah so
first one I ever got was on my neck here
and that was 201 so that's the area code
where I'm from then I think the second
one I ever got was the first one on my
face which was 96 I was the year I was
born
so
growing up I've just always done what I
wanted like I don't even think twice
about it I'm just doing it like whatever
I wake up no matter the weather no
matter where I'm at whatever I want to
wear I'm aware whatever haircut I want
to get or whatever I'm gonna do
so it was just like daily things I'm
just waking up I'm like all right I'm
gonna just go get tatted today like I
never got a tattoo and went like yo and
like went on the Internet or went on
Instagram and stuff like that maybe a
selfie or two but I never like did
anything for an audience or whatever so
yeah I just it was like a daily thing I
just kept going with it it's like so
it's like a creative thing and
I was always good with Photoshop and
stuff so I would always plan out the
tattoos I would want to get so like I'll
take a modeling picture of me like a
portrait or I'll take a quick selfie and
then like I'll Sketcher to draw it out
and then place it so that's why all of
them like look so good and never like
faded or anything so I it was like a
creative process so like
sketching and drawing it out and then
going to the artist and handing it to
him and then it being done it was like
whoa so yeah and then you know as I'm
getting them of course it's mixed
reviews you got 50 of people and love
what you like whoa so cool awesome and
and inspiring to them like imma get this
and you want to make me get that then
the other 50 all haters and
I took it so personal at first you know
especially even with music you know
people just hate and I took a soul
personal and I let it derail any
progress of of my life and then you
can't listen to that stuff
right it took so many years to get to
this point and
eventually I got to a point where I was
like
I understand now it's frustrating but
it's it's literally the insecurities and
there's no way somebody's gonna look at
somebody they've never met or never
known before and just talk negative
about you but it's just the insecurity
they just looking at you like
how is somebody this comfortable or like
this free or just doesn't give a [ __ ]
like and they're just gonna do what they
want
and instead of like congratulating or
being like Oh that's different or
that's what's up they're just like
something inside them in the insecurity
they're just gonna take it out not even
me anybody else that's just comfortable
of being themselves and it's a sad thing
but it is what it is your goals are not
to work at a banker
or Starbucks right so
so maybe the face tax work yo you see
wow you get it yeah the strangest thing
a lot of people kept telling me like as
they would see me like what are you
gonna do for a job now
you gotta like work on how you're gonna
respond to that because like you just
want to spaz out on somebody because
that's just common sense but it it
covers with it so but yeah we we're not
doing nothing regular yeah
free spirit what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
most important lesson in my life
and 26 years of living the most
important lesson in my life I would say
laughs
foreign
loving yourself
loving yourself
I've gone through my life so many times
with expectations of people
I set the standard so high for myself so
I'm so hard on myself
so when I meet people when I become
friends with people build a relationship
or you got a partner a girlfriend
whatever
I'm always going through life
whatever my ambitions are my passion my
energy
I'd be expecting that out of anybody
else that's around me
and when I don't get that then I get so
frustrated
and I'm spazzing out and I realize that
that keeps happening and then I had to
like talk to a lot of people and take
accountability and learn that you you
just can't go through life expecting the
next person
to just understand because you're just
going to be frustrated forever
yeah loving yourself is the key you
can't you can't go through life
expecting validation or acceptance from
anybody you can't do something and then
want the Rewards or the respect for it
yeah you just you just gotta love
yourself and
people be trying to critique you and try
to act like it's advice but they're
really trying to like
you know put you in a box stuff like
that you just can't listen to any of
that you know appreciate all the love
you get on along this journey but
positive or negative you just gotta stay
focused on whatever it is you're doing
that that's probably the biggest lesson
somebody just said something to me the
other day he said who you are isn't
transactional but it is transformative
and I was like
oh I related so much because I feel like
I'll be trying to like inject on people
kind of my passion and when they don't
I'm frustrated so he's like you could
you could put a song out right now you
could put a positive video on Instagram
right now you could do something
nobody's gonna understand that it's not
gonna go nowhere you can't expect it to
go like that but over time it's gonna
slowly affect the people and they're
gonna understand it said deep down
whatever it is you're doing you got to
understand people are fascinated with it
they wanna do whatever it is you doing
or they love it but they just can't do
it for whatever type of Lifestyle they
got right now they don't have it inside
so you can't take it personal you just
gotta let them flow through life or
whatever and eventually the it'll come
around to them
yeah but loving yourself for sure I
think so much of self-love comes from
not having
I mean it's it's so important to have
your parents
loving you as a kid which which sounds
like maybe you didn't have so much of it
right so but but some of the people that
are the most loving I've met in life
never really had
right you go through life so yeah you go
through life so
like broken and seeking the validation
because you never had it like you said
from the parents or whatever so you kind
of go through life as a question mark
like like who am I what am I doing wrong
like what's what why is all this
happening so
that's why people end up they they go to
the drugs or they go outside or they go
partying they go around a group of
people that's that's just not
in their best interest they they might
end up on the Internet doing some stupid
or viral or
um
yeah so we can't like really we can't
judge people at all for what they do and
no matter how wacky it is or whatever
it may be annoying or just messed up but
at the same time there's a reason for
why everybody's acting the way they are
so I just feel like we'll move forward
as a society way better if we don't
judge at all if we just have the peace
and the love and just have communication
we're going to be able to figure
anything out but what this social media
is is wild man everybody just pulls you
up and judges you within five seconds
with they look at a picture they look at
a video
we can't even have discussions anymore
it's like War a verse B one verse two
you can't even be able to give your
opinion without receiving anything so
yes it's tough there's so many yeah it's
like what's your biggest fear what's
your biggest worry at this point in your
life
foreign
okay I wouldn't say fear
as in like something I'm really scared
of physically because what do you worry
about what are you stressed out about
I would say the thing that stresses me
out the most is the world not
understanding
my message if I was to leave this earth
tomorrow I'm not present here anymore
and they don't understand the message
it's like
what what did God put me through all
this for like even if even if tomorrow
whatever happens like I blow up
however it is from whatever type of
Talent OR field it is the money and the
cars and the designer clothes and the
girls and like Mansions or whatever like
that's that's never been my thing since
a kid at all I never strive for that
so none of that matters
so famous in our audience and not
for me it's just a message if they're
not hearing the message it's like that's
why I'm always trying to promote peace
and love
communication we need to come together
as a community we we can't just have
each other's numbers we can't just have
each other's emails we can't just follow
each other on Instagram but then never
communicate with one another because we
don't know what somebody's going through
on a daily basis like we not promised
the next hour the next day so whenever
you're speaking to somebody if you're on
the phone text FaceTime Instagram DM in
person eating interview like this
whatever the situation is
that could be the first or last time you
see someone and
I feel like that's why I've struggled so
much with trying to have a presence on
the the internet because every time I
try to speak my piece it doesn't really
go anywhere it doesn't get out there so
I'm like how am I am not going to be
sitting here on the internet and then
you see all the nonsense
in the algorithm that gets pushed to the
top
it's like the world knows what they're
doing and they're trying to poison us
all and it's a toxic thing but
starting from right now from this
interview right now
if I leave here
and I just
am silent for the rest of my life and
don't say anything
what good is that like even if I have
one person that watches me every day or
listens to a song or watches a video if
it's one person that's better than zero
like we can't and not just meet anybody
out there that's related at all to
anything I just said here on feels my
energy or whatever if you be silent
we're not going nowhere and then they're
going to win because they killing us off
like
it would be such a disservice to the
higher power and God like we blessed
with a life and it's so frustrating like
no I feel like nobody's been more
frustrated with trying to get over the
hump than me I struggle so much with it
but so many people around me like as
many negative messages I might get the
positive so many people send me so many
messages every day and it's like yo keep
going you gotta keep going you inspiring
me I love the music the video is so good
I love what you speak
so there's people out there that that
see you they feel what you're doing and
it'll go eventually like what you said
earlier you're doing things for yourself
everything's gonna fall into place
and like I'm sure you like how you were
telling me you didn't even think this
channel was gonna go when you started
imagine you were like you came in the
skid row and was like all right let me
find the whack this the wackiest looking
person and put them on an interview and
hope I get a million views and YouTube
pays me that's a sick approach like
nobody
you're never gonna get far doing that
and I feel like that's why
this channel is the way it is I haven't
seen another channel that kind of
documents this type of stuff so if
you're chasing money I think you'll
ultimately fail you won't you won't have
what it takes to continue
and it's going to take a lot of a lot of
perseverance and time and effort to make
anything work so if you're doing it for
the money you're going to run out of gas
if you're doing it because you love it
or you think it's meaningful
you'll have what it takes to last we got
we got we gotta quote that we got a
sound bites it's too long to quote and
we yeah we got a sound bite that those
are the facts and my whole life growing
up that's everybody was talking about
money this money that and growing up in
the music especially now more than ever
it's all about money money money and I
got more than you and I spent this on my
car and I spent this on my outfit and
I took my girl shopping and spent this
much like I'm living in this building
and it's this much it's so disgusting
and growing up that's all I heard like
yo you don't got a job yet like yo you
don't got no money yet and these are the
same people that told me this when I was
the young kid and they were the older
ones and a lot of these people are still
in that same position because like you
just said they were chasing money you're
gonna ultimately fail I never thought I
would see I'm about to see 27.
like people that I was younger under
they're 30 40
back where I'm from and and they haven't
moved like they there's in the same
position and I don't talk negative it's
not like a competition
I'm just saying these were the same
people and Community trying to like
scold me and and be like you're never
gonna amount to nothing and we talking
we talk we about to be in 2023 and you
still like
in the same position it the money
doesn't do anything for me it and I have
all this experience from places I've
went and people I've met and
I have that for the rest of my life that
memory lives forever like if I have a if
I have a child right now just an example
I'm never gonna run out of stories like
I could sit there all day and just have
stories and stuff as opposed to if I
have a kid and I'm like yeah I've been
in I've been in this area for 30 years I
still live with my parents and I work my
nine to five job and I thought I was a
scholar in school but then I went
nowhere I dropped out or I went to
Community College but then stopped but
it's the same type of stuff and I just
never wanted that and nobody believed
nobody I was like imma do it
and I did it for myself and I'm still
here I'm just shocked I'm still here so
yeah but yeah everybody out there money
don't like don't do anything in life
with that as the number one goal if
you're doing whatever it is you want to
do anything that should come your way is
going to come with it regardless if you
waking up every day like
yeah like you said you're gonna
ultimately fail It's just sad yeah like
how you just asked earlier well what am
I scared of and I just said that that as
well if the world just thinks money runs
the world and that's what you need to
succeed and and you're above somebody
and you could talk down to somebody
because you you had a certain status or
you have certain amount of money in your
bank account that's the most disgusting
thing like for sure and that's why
I love the fact that I took the decision
and I and I went through this whole
homeless grind still on this adventure
because it taught me so much
growing up I was always into
like I had so many video games I would
hustle to get my own stuff so I always
had like the sneaker collection or the
clothing all that kind of stuff before
was like cool and accepted
and then seeing it become the norm and
everybody then acting cool with it and
I'm like I was just doing this and
everybody was like what are you doing so
then when I come out here and I'm on
this homeless grind I have nothing but
just a backpack
you can't carry any of that stuff with
you it's all material stuff so that
taught me so much about loving yourself
being comfortable with who you are
because you can't wake up every day and
put on whatever pair of shoes you want
you can't go in the closet and grab
whatever or go to the store you got no
money you got nothing you trying to
survive every day and push through so
you gotta take what you can get and what
you know you're being handed to or
whatever the Resource Centers or
whatever can do for you
and that's what I learned and I've
gotten more love in my whole life
out here than I did 20 some years
growing up back home
and I'm thinking back home I was the man
I had this I had that and I come out
here with nothing and I'm getting more
love and respect than I ever did in my
life I'm like I'm just putting random
clothes together that I could find in
the in these thrift stores uh whatever
they're donating to me whatever shoes I
can put on and
it was more than ever before so if if
you truly are yourself you're never
going to be out of place
that's what it is the the yeah the money
doesn't even matter free spirit thank
you so much
sharing your story very interesting I
appreciate you doing this and I this is
how I know it was meant to be because
when I started watching you
um so yeah to everybody out there I
found this channel when I first came to
LA and I was in the shelters and stuff
and then I started watching it then
about a week and a half ago two weeks
ago I stumbled upon your channel again I
don't know how it just came across I was
on YouTube I was like oh I remember this
I started watching a few
and then I said you know what I woke up
the next day or so I was like let me go
on his YouTube and try to find his
contact information and let me just hit
him up it's up in the about section at
the header I click the about found the
email and I was like oh okay and you
sent the video yeah I hit the email at
first I was like is this really Mark and
then you responded instantly I was like
oh snap and I was like okay let me send
you a vid real quick because I'm not a
typer like I don't text either if people
communicate with me I send a video or I
do voice memos I'm just all about energy
so I sent you and then you responded
instantly that's our words and I was
like yo it's meant to be like God
connected us for a reason so yeah
appreciate you doing this interview and
to everybody out there no matter who you
are where you live in what's your status
you outside you in a mansion you got a
car you taking the bus to train every
day you walk in whatever it is whatever
your skin tone gay straight by tall
short
overweight skinny whatever like
just peace and love don't judge anybody
let's learn communication and come
together and just never give up we like
nobody nobody should have to resort to a
point of killing themselves nobody
should have to resort to being alone or
sleeping in the streets or be out in the
rain like none of that so yeah that's
all I'm gonna say peace and love free
spirit appreciate your mark and that's
all
thank you very much